Selena gets the Google Doodle treatment
plus your first look at Michael
Jackson's Halloween special
[Music]
hello friends it is a day of music icons
up in the daily Denny today starting
with Selena have you been on the Google
homepage today because the late Tejano
singer was honored with a Google doodle
on the anniversary of her debut album's
release and twenty-two years after her
tragic death take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Google's serving me with all the fields
you guys I have literally watched this a
dozen times and get this Perla composts
the woman behind this amazing and
touching doodle told Billboard she
delayed the project because she was so
passionate about it and says she wanted
to not only get it right she wanted to
make it great with the help of Selena's
family it took compost illustrator Kevin
Laughlin and team two years to make sure
the doodle was a true reflection of her
short the story life a story and career
that has taken a life of its own since
Elena's death in 1995 and of course the
movie starring Jennifer Lopez earlier
this year are Deidre Behar scored a
special tour inside the superstars at
Memorial Museum Selena's sister Suzy and
dad Abraham looked back on Selena's life
and legacy today she had this beautiful
personality and she had this amazing
talent and combining all that together I
think that that's why we're still
talking about her and it's like all over
again and it's a new generation
embracing her Selena passed in 1995 and
the movie came out in 1997 that's a
pretty quick turnaround why did you guys
decide to do this so close to her
passing I wanted the world to know about
my kids my daughter just to make sure
that Selena was portrayed in the right
light in the right way listen we are on
a Selena fix here at et online and up on
our YouTube channel now makeup artist
Etienne ortega shows us how to create
Selena's timeless look in our new Beauty
series how to Hollywood just in time for
Halloween so get at it all right now
from one icon to another music legend
getting the animated treatment Michael
Jackson when you think of Halloween it's
hard not to picture zombie MJ and
thriller right and now for the first
time the hits of the late King of Pop
will provide the soundtrack to Michael
Jackson's Halloween a one-hour animated
special set to MJ's tunes among the
stars lending their voices is Big Bang
Theory's Jim Parsons who plays a
scarecrow who loves to dance
sound familiar I'm hey man heads ground
keeper here and this is my crew well
this is like um celebration of Michael
Jackson music also in the guise of a
Halloween story it's this whole tale of
what it means to not conform to be
yourself and let your freak flag fly as
it were there was no way I was gonna say
no because anything that's celebrating
Michael Jackson music was just really
enjoyable to be a part of
amen to that Jim back he says his
favorite Michael Jackson song is human
nature
mine are don't stop to get enough and
man in the mirror come on I dare I dare
you to figure out what your favorite MJ
song is I know it's hard to choose but I
do want to hear them and Michael
Jackson's Halloween airs October 27 on
CBS all right from Tejano music biggest
star - the King of Pop and now the CMT's
artist of the year Keith Urban I'm
covering all my bases today guys our
very own sophie scholl AC was
exclusively with Keith as you rehearse
for tomorrow night's big show and I'm so
excited because she joins us from
Nashville now hey so hey Danny I am here
at the scre mermen Symphony Center in
Nashville Tennessee Keith Urban just
rehearsed he's gonna be performing
tomorrow at CMT's artists of the year
event congratulations are of course an
order as an artist of the year that's
such a huge honor thank you what does
this honour mean to you just to be
amongst this group of people thing all
of this year's is huge
you know it's been a it's just been a
magical year and I particularly I think
for again for my audience who have been
so passionate and supportive of rip cord
as an album and the tour it's it's just
it's changed my life really I love a
Keith Urban love song I want to know
what are the keys what are like the
three steps to making a really great
love song honesty
that's it that's one stab that's it yeah
honesty and mobility I like that
okay well Nicole be your date tomorrow
yes yes you will I was supportive you
guys are of each other we're just best
friends as well as married you know yeah
we're everything amazing stuff
forgive the loud drums in the guitar
guys it was a rehearsal after all we
have more with Keith and how the CMT
Artists of the year will address the
recent Vegas tragedy that's all tonight
on ET and will of course be covering
that and Mura ET online.com be sure to
like and share this video I am because
anything for Salinas